Palestinian leaders say they've managed
to control possible sources of
coronavirus infections
except one tens of thousands of
Palestinian workers in Israel at first
the Palestinian government and Israel as
those who commute daily from the
occupied West Bank not to do that and
remain in Israel for a few weeks but
scenes like these angered Palestinians
Israeli buses leaving workers showing
corona like symptoms by the side of
Palestinian roads that and the growing
number of infections in Israel led the
Palestinian government to ask workers to
return home jaffa o day a father of six
came back to his village of their amarte
near Ramallah he's in quarantine now
with 8 other workers our Israeli
employer was keen on having us work at
first otherwise he would have replaced
us and that would have harmed us
financially later he asked us to leave
and the workers stopped most workers
have Israeli permits and traveled to
Israel and it's illegal settlements
through military checkpoints others
sneak through by roots in the hills it's
almost impossible for the Palestinian
Authority to track all arrivals
community-based committees especially in
remote villages are helping with
movement restrictions so far the
Palestinian Authority is trying to
organize medical check-ups for returning
workers those who test positive for the
virus are taken into compulsory
quarantine centers while others are
asked to self isolate them in Israel
we've asked Israel to test workers for
infections or that they allow them to
come back in separate groups so that we
can give them the medical service they
need workers in Israel form around 20%
of the Palestinian workforce with more
people now as to stay home the already
weak economy will suffer further damage
[Music]
but instead will
other will have the effect of reducing
overall demand in the economy and
helping to further depress even the
ability of the national economy to
rebound once some of these measures are
lifted it's not clear whether Israel
would allow those workers back after the
Passover holiday the Palestinian
Authority cannot fully control their
movement and so far officials have been
trying to appeal to the workers sense of
civic duty but it's hard to tell if that
gambit will work with Ibrahim Al Jazeera
the occupied West Bank